so please join me in welcoming our
moderator of the second panel animal
yakky she's an assistant professor of
architecture at the MIT Anna hello take
your seat we're entering a red panel all
right I want to since I'm no longer
native I nah wanna you know tell you
that it's a great pleasure for me to
take on the moderation of this panel and
I want to thank the architecture and
state team for coming up with a topic as
I think it allows us to take a fresh
look at the post-war and cross some of
the common discursive divides that
genuinely reproduce the political
divides of the Cold War and I know that
you know just just before me Reinhold
the suggested that you know post-war is
maybe not the most important topic to
connect to the architecture in state and
that may be true but what I think is
interesting is that in Reverse the
attaching architecture in the state to a
post-war topic actually does open up
something really interesting and so just
in this last year of acting as a
moderator in various history theory
panels now I encountered more of a
critical mass of people working on what
I've been insisting on calling second
world topics then in the entire eight
years of my writing on a second world
topic and I don't know if this is just a
factor of sort of having felt
particularly lonely in the writing
process or something really is changing
now when it comes to the topics you're
going to see here that the state was one
of the most important agents in the
second world production of
architecture is a truism with the
capacity to prevent us from actually
understanding the mechanisms and
practices that constitute the history of
the second world and in general and its
architectural history specifically and I
want to in a way call back something
here from the outset that actually each
law says really eloquently yesterday a
kind of Altos Aryan caution that the
state is not a thing and it doesn't have
a center even when its bureaucratic and
ideological apparatuses are centrally
organized if that is even when you know
it employs all of the architects that
operate on its geographic territory now
and you know i'm going to set up a few
things that are for me interesting about
these topics so there is a self-serving
framework for the panel but i like
holding on to the notion of the second
world even though that's not a term
that's been consistently used to
describe this geopolitical context that
we're going to deal with in all the
papers but I like holding on to it
because it highlights the real
structural that is economic discursive
and even cultural difference from the
first and the third world and which in
and that difference inevitably
constitutes the products and the of the
second world while it simultaneously
highlights to me the fact that we have
not yet developed a real interpretive
framework that is specific to that
difference the second world and by this
I mean to say not that you know that
even basically as each a historian of
the Second World material may have
developed in their own work and attitude
and even a theory about what it means to
do history or write history of these
artifacts we don't have enough of a
public discussion about methodological
and interpretive specificity of this
context now so as as I'm happy that
we have a conference that allows us to
cross the political boundaries that
general divide the discourse I'm also
happy that we actually have a panel
that's going to concentrate on some of
the issues that are going to be specific
to the second world and so but on the
other hand so if we in fact have a
critical mass now which I'm saying I'm
feeling that maybe we don't need a
general theory of second world history
but this is something that I would like
to talk about in the conversation
afterwards so the range of topics in
this panel Maps historically across the
Stalinist era and the fall and indeed
each of the papers will take up among
other things the issue that was
suggested in the title of the panel of
second world's architects inevitable
task of interpreting and delivering a
social agenda through design but there
are other things that could be maybe the
point one of our general theory of cycle
world history but so the I will just
introduce the speakers all now in
advance and I'm not going to come out to
introduce you before that before each
paper but the first picker is Greg
Castillo and his paper is our magnetic
kookiest is the associate professor at
the College of Environmental Design
University of California at Berkeley and
he will be telling us about
reconstructing German cities and
citizens a la France kiya who is a
doctoral candidate in history theory and
criticism at MIT her project or her
paper will be on people's parks in the
Soviet Union Richard Anderson who is a
doctoral candidates a few days away from
being just finished in the history of
architecture at the department of art
history and archaeology at columbia and
he will be telling us about an
experimental project in moscow and the
papers called a new way of life so
please take over
thank you Cold War Berlin was an
unparalleled laboratory for the
interaction of states and architecture
there are two alternative cities of
industrial modernity arose side by side
from the rubble of Hitler's Germany
divided Berlin demonstrates that there
were two post-war international styles
the neoclassicism of a Soviet Imperium
and the American influenced modernism of
the Marshall Plan and NATO in East
Berlin Socialist Realist the Socialist
Realist Stalin la which you see on the
left was a byproduct of a Stalinist
economy in its urban planning in West
Berlin the hunt Sofia told residential
district on the right built for the
International housing exposition of 1957
or interval for sure made transnational
consumer capitalism at home in West
Germany through international style
modernism intervals apartment block by
gropius in the architects collaborative
is perhaps the perfect symbol for an
imagined community conjoining the bimah
republic of the 20s and the federal
republic of the 50s the to quote good
Germany's championed by post-war America
socialist realism and international
style modernism were far more
significant than mere Brandon devices
for the cultural division of Germany
cold war reconstruction mobilized
opposing programs for social and human
reform explicitly intended to re-educate
former third reich citizens competing
architectures of state were
infrastructures for competing postwar
subjectivities the worker activists hair
alized on the on the left in a poster
for East Berlin socialist reconstruction
and the Marshall Plan consumers citizen
glamorized on the right in a fashion
spread shot on location at West Berlin's
interval these human and urban
reconstruction efforts are the focus of
my reach
search which asserts as its fundamental
premise that the objects and subjects
shown here are so intertwined even
symbiotic that their histories must be
written in tandem one of these programs
the one on the left seems obviously
state-managed while that on the right
represented by symbols of consumer
choice often evades analysis as an
architecture of state I take on this
misconception at a new monograph Cold
War on the homefront it examines the
State Department's use of suburban model
homes to pitch the benefits of treat
free trade and to undercut the appeal of
communism in post-war Europe at the 1952
show were building a better life shown
on the left visitors examined human
subjects making use of modernist
furnishings manufactured in Marshall
Plan member states a press release
explained quote just as these items from
the various countries combined to form a
homogeneous whole so the nation's
themselves can combine to form a
homogeneous community West Berlin's
better life home drew exhibition drew
crowds from both West and East Germany
remember that until the infamous wall
was built in nineteen sixty one divided
Berlin was in open city where citizens
could simply walk across the Cold War's
geopolitical divide American home
propaganda efforts in West Berlin paved
the way for the 1959 Nixon Khrushchev
debate in Moscow at which a sunshine
yellow GE kitchen came to embody the
clash of Cold War civilizations the
trajectory chronicled in Cold War on the
homefront that ends our product
placement so let's return to the topic
at hand socialist realism and its
civilizing mission according to East
German party leader vowed to evict the
west toward emigration of bauhaus former
Bauhaus masters revealed the true
politics of modernism and I quote today
where are the architects who represented
the bow
such as gropius Mies van der Rohe and
others they are in America they seem to
like it there and from this we can infer
that they have decided in favor of
American imperialism end quote the East
German Politburo declared war on
modernism in 1951 the party newspaper at
noise Island proclaimed that quote in
architecture what hinders us most is the
underlying functionalist philosophy of
many East German architects the party
condemned international style modernism
as a plot to quote disassociate the
people from their native land language
and culture so that they adopt the
American lifestyle and join in the
slavery of American imperialism end
quote the same point was made by
comparing the new us-funded free
university in west berlin with the
architecture of a bank headquarters seen
below it in the publication national
reconstruction and the task of a new
german architecture socialist realist
design required a quote connection to
past exemplars specifically to the
legacy of Prussian neoclassicism in East
Germany rather than the Bauhaus
influences of the West's international
style which was of course another
connection to past exemplars one that
just happened to be despised by the
party inculcating an appreciation for
beauty and its political ideology
comprised an important mission of East
Germany's at scenes dicta 20 or educated
dictatorship as the regime has recently
been described Buddha breached the party
boss maintained that members of the
Intelligencia who failed to grasp the
fundamentals of beauty demonstrated
their alienation from the working class
and as the East German architect Hans
hawk explained quote we know that
political consciousness is for many not
sufficiently developed to be to be able
to enable citizens to distinguish
beautiful and good from ugly and bad
only when such material education
penetrates the citizens innermost being
including the world of his dreams
fantasies will change his bear fruit end
quote in short Socialist Realist Beauty
defined the beholder making beauty and
architectural term as loaded with
portent as function was for modernists
the result was a national reconstruction
policy in which the creation of
environments saturated with beauty
assumed strategic importance in the
project to forge socialist citizens the
process and products of socialist
realist reconstruction yielded a bumper
crop of post-war subjectivities from
culturally enlightened apartment
dwellers to heroic construction workers
even party secretary ulbricht was cast
or recast as quote the master builder of
socialism rather than surveying these
multiple personalities I'll focuses
presentation on a professional
reclamation project that is the
transformation of former East German
modernists into a fresh cohort of
neoclassicism the Deutsche ba Academy a
design bureaucracy modeled on a Soviet
Academy of architects was founded in
nineteen fifty-one to promote the
Gospels the gospel of socialist realism
in East Germany the new organization
claimed the bombed ruin of shingles
historic val Academy in Berlin as its
future headquarters socialist realism
approached neoclassicism similarly as an
entitlement to be expropriated from its
former version wom Astor's just as with
other forms of property as elucidated in
the balcony journal quote comrade stalin
following the precepts of lenin has
determined that it is not possible to
build communism without appropriating
the knowledge and cultural legacy of all
human history including the artistic
heritage end quote in contrast to
socialist neoclassicism Bauhaus design
and its international style descendant
were said to be capitalist phenomenon
and this news came as a shock to former
via our modernists like bow Academy
associate Hans Hall who
who noted that quote the accusations
made against the Bauhaus then must be
made against all architects who are
products of this time East German
modernists had become by definition
enemies of the new socialist state as a
man with an architectural a deviant past
Hans hop played a crucial role in
reorienting East Germany's former
modernists born in 1890 Huck was
classically trained but joined the
modernist have in the mid-1920s as
proclaimed in the strip windows and
curved corner of his 1928 cinema in
knigsberg which you see on the top
right his practice collapsed during the
Depression and in 1939 he enter enter
German military service for a second
time already is quite a mature man at
war's end he migrated to Dresden where
he draft a plan for the city's
reconstruction based on the Cartesian
forms and Cartesian logic of liqueur
Dozier's 1933 vilified use as seen on
the lower right like many other
politically galvanized East German
architects hop had believed that the new
socialist Germany would pick up where
interwar modernism left off he look he
relocated to East Berlin in 1954 post in
the East German Ministry of construction
in the same year that a team of its
bureaucrats headed off for retraining at
the union of soviet architects in moscow
pup became a member of the Baloch ought
to be in 1951 his award-winning design
that year for the max who did house of
culture in interval inborn displayed his
conversion to socialist realism both as
a designer and as a newly minted member
of a Stalinist inteligencia as an
instant authority on the new socialist
architecture hop bemoaned the fact that
so few of his colleagues could design
quote beautiful details that come
together harmonically in a beautiful
hole end quote this handicap he said
revealed the pervasive effect of
american cultural Barbara's ation
because quote all that is true
we knew is developed out of the old end
quote only a return to German tradition
could resolve its aesthetic and
ideological crisis hopes matsu to house
of culture blazed the trail to achieving
the party's mandate for a new German
architecture its preliminary drafts were
published as a lesson in how architects
might overcome modernist Evian's this
paper trail of design development
progressing from modernism to
neoclassicism is absolutely unique in
post-war architecture the immediate
prototype for the East German house of
culture was a Soviet workers club an
institution charged with transforming
laborers into the new men and women of
communism typically attached to an
industrial facility the Soviet workers
club advanced the party's occupation of
everyday life within a Stalinist company
town infrastructure in 1950 East
Germany's Politburo proposed the
construction of a facility quote based
on the model of a Soviet house of
culture for workers at the max Wittek
steel mill and unto that in bone and as
with any other Commission of national
consequence it was awarded to the
Deutsche ba Academy where was routed to
Hobbs Atelier working with associate
Joseph Joseph Kaiser hop produced a
design that achieved canonic status as a
monument to the nation's five-year plan
and you see it on the right in a
five-year plan economic poster
celebrating it as a example of Lenin's
saying art belongs to the people
constructed from 1952 to 1955 the
finished building included performance
rehearsal and exhibit halls game rooms
offices cafe youth club and library at
gabled block containing the 1,200 seat
auditorium in its brown faux a provided
a dominant central element for a
sprawling cross axial composition
flanked by projecting babbled wings the
monumental portico framed by smaller
brackets evoked to the Brandenburg Gate
the heraldic symbol that graced the bow
academy co is shown on the left an
article in the professional journal
plannin on balan provided a
behind-the-scenes look at the process by
which the architects initial proposal in
the detested modernist style evolved
into a socialist realist masterpiece the
essay begins by repudiating the notion
of artistic creativity as a virtual
fantasy quote with regard to the
architects profession when we
increasingly speak about planning rather
than designing our living language
unconsciously registers a transformation
of method this change expresses the fact
that in increasingly an increasing
proportion of this occupations creative
work no longer follows an intuitive
flash and its realization but but
proceeds from logical thought processes
developed within an awakened
consciousness end quote the rhetoric may
have echoed interwar functionalism but
its outcome was quite the opposite four
consecutive design schemes for the house
of culture illustrated this appeal to
socialist realist rationalism an initial
proposal joined a trapezoidal auditorium
to an orthogonal block via a curving
glass gallery which you see of course on
the left its rhythmic forms evoke the
feel of Austra Niemeyer's brazilian work
of the 1940s early 1940s which you see
on the right and i need to note that
hops article did not mention any
architectural precedents so
these comparisons which you'll see on
the right are all always mine the design
team rejected this approach which was
said by them to express quote
cheerfulness rather than monumentality
this was a benign verdict indeed given
the fact that the party's denunciation
of modernism made this a form of
aesthetic and ideological subversion a
second attempt presented in a
perspective drawing at the top showed
hip roofed blocks arrayed asymmetrically
around a courtyard and rendered them in
a stern Teutonic vernacular the scheme
is uncomfortably reminiscent of third
right design as evidence when compared
to a public building built in Nuremberg
during Hitler's rule the team's third
proposal look to an even more distant
generation of German architecture for
inspiration agglomerating much of the
buildings programme beneath a single
gabled roof framed by rows have engaged
plasters and arches the third
perspective design recapitulates the
wall treatments of Hans pot cigs grosses
shell fieldhouse of 1919 in Berlin these
proposals were said to illustrate the
team's progress for the final design of
the mocks makuta house of culture a
final design that was progressing toward
this symmetrical massing framed by
forward thrusting wings now Western
heretics would likely interpret its
design process as an archaeological dig
through a succession of architectural
non-sequiturs beginning with mid-century
modernism descending through the
subsequent strata of Third Reich hi Matt
suits and then interwar Expressionism
and finally hitting paydirt by an
unearthing Prussian neoclassicism which
after all was really the foregone
conclusion of hops design process while
such an explanation might satisfy
Western cold warriors it is
fundamentally a historical ignoring
rather than
feeling but role played by ideology in
cultivating architectures Socialist
Realist intelligentsia a far different
interpretation emerges when we considers
hops account intended for the
Enlightenment of former modernists in
the context of East Germany's at seems
dictator or educated dictatorship as
historian Gregg Ian notes quote the East
German citizen of the 1950s was
understood in cognitive terms as a
subject who required education rearing
and consciousness raising and needed to
be protected from dangerous diversions
and detours end quote in hops article
the emphasis on planned logic rather
than unpredictable inspiration attempts
to pledge to protect fledgling socialist
realists from their own DVD deviationist
dangers in fact hop and kaisers approach
to socialist realist architecture
strongly resembled East Germany's quote
new method of art education for children
presented in the context there of
socialist school reform according to a
1950 article in the pedagogical journal
de neue schule the idea that quote
gifted children had a quote special
talent for art was a pernicious legacy
of bourgeois education which had
cultivated grade-school elites quote
drawing painting sculpture and building
and working are things that can be
taught and learned not only technique
but also content can be imparted content
in fact was the key to primary school
art education according to proponents of
the new approach quote just as we demand
healthy realism in every work of art so
also in children's our is form
determined by the priority of content
what content is obligatory in teaching
as befits our German democracy social
content which stirs the entire nation
must predominate shepherding children
from primitive dabbling to the realistic
depiction of socialist themes like man
his
work constituted quote the developmental
process of drawing the new Yeshua
article illustrated this process with a
developmental timeline of children's
drawings the sequence begins with
scribbles and then proceeds to a lumpy
proto torso and also a spiral with a
line indicating a speeding car drawings
then come to mimic forms found in nature
then as the child matures succeed in
depicting human movement body parts and
body forms and finally the process is
comes to an end it comes to a conclusion
in this article with an image from an
eighth graders drawing project so the
culmination of this developmental
process in which representational
actress accuracy was the measure both of
aesthetic skills and proper
socialization was illustrated by an
eighth graders drawing assignment on the
theme industrial and farm workers
according to Socialist Realist child
pedagogue one could detect the promise
of an awakened political consciousness
even in a toddler scroll since it
contained the living kernel of what
educators called quote healthy realism
hop was similarly able to discern the
promise of realist form lying dormant
within an abstract modernist diagram the
notion that architectural ontogeny
recapitulating the phylogeny of
kindergarten art was a discovery of
profound importance to East German
designers mired in their own modernist
past remember socialist realist doctrine
equated modernism with capitalist acts
of barbarity including quote quote the
uprooting of national culture the
destruction of national consciousness
and direct support for the militaristic
policies of American imperialism end
quote former modernists thus became
potential traders every time they picked
the pencil hops article depicted
modernist barbarity in a far gentler
light more like that of the unsocialized
child who scrawls were in unwitting
betrayal of the party mandate for
healthy realism and like the toddler's
eventual grasp of realism which required
no quote special talent no quote
creative intuition the skill of planning
rather than designing one's way towards
socialist realism was available to any
architect willing to work at it within
the context of the party's Cultural
Revolution hops account of design
development was profoundly optimistic
proposing that post-war Beauty defined
as neoclassicism could be spun from
modernist drawers but another set of
design schemes by hop for the Mac suited
house of culture that were suppressed
for pub from publication from was two
generations could easily have demolished
his statement of faith in would be
socialist realists sketches held back
from the article revealed pops pre
extant fluency in the handling of
neoclassical form and proportion and
detail a skill gained through the rigors
of his bows arts influenced design
education circa 1910 architects nearing
retirement age like hop turned out to be
much better prepared for their new role
as social as Stalinist cultural
revolutionaries than younger colleagues
trained in modernist design methods what
the BAL academy really needed was a
fresh cohort of bo's arts trained
designers a fact soon reflected in East
German architectural pedagogy but until
the new generation of neoclassicism
online hops article fuelled hopes among
former modernists that like children
struggling to draw model workers they
too could attain the goals of a
socialist realist you see incivility
velocities through guidance and hard
work in coming to terms publicly with
his modernist past and providing a way
to follow in his footsteps hop was
inspirational if not exactly in the way
implied by his article he had come to
embody the merging of individual and
establishment goals that characterized a
socialist realist bureaucracy and its
hierarchical ranks of cultural
revolutionaries out of the sediment of a
design career well on the way to
retirement had climbed a new man of
post-war socialism thank you very much
I'm very happy to be able to develop
some of the intentions of the previous
presentations presentation here namely
the relationship between the subject and
the object and I would like to thank
their organizers of this conference
first of all and are now for her careful
reading of the paper and everybody here
for coming the major public park in the
Soviet Union which the officials proudly
named the central park of culture and
rest was opened in Moscow in 1928 is a
highly ordered and programmatic side and
here on this photograph by her nose
Meyer you can see how it looked like
sometime in the middle or in their early
1930s when he was in Moscow designed as
a trial ground for socialist space it
also served as a place for ideological
propaganda its first architects were
Constantine Monica and Ellie Suzuki both
renowned members of the of the oven God
however after the war in the 1940s and
50s the park of culture and dressed or
Gorky Park as it became known after 1932
had significantly changed its program
and was turned into a mixture of a
strolling park and an entertainment park
like Coney Island at first sight the
conflict of the initial idea and the
final result which persisted in this
form throughout the rest of the Soviet
era seems to fit into the narrative
dismantling of Soviet avant-garde by the
state after 1932 which is well known to
Western scholarship however in this
presentation I will add another
dimension to the opposition between the
state and architecture in late Stalin a
Soviet Union introducing the third
player the people i will demonstrate
that the Soviet state was not as a
militant and powerful as a top ten seems
to be rather than juxtaposed on the
stage with practice and architects I
will accept that it was to a certain
degree ratified by them point to the
collective agency of the people as it as
its more successful opponent and I will
start with the revolutionary ideals
which were developed by architects in
the late 1920s daughters and then I will
go on to their prosaic reality with with
which these ideals were confronted and
then I will conclude with their results
in layout of the park the initial agenda
of the park was outlined in the
competition brief and developed in some
of the entries to the competition of
1931 which took place three years after
the park was already open to the public
such anxious as those submitted by
architects we see a keansburg the one
the drawing on the right and constantine
manic of the one on the left are
characterized by the high level of mass
involvement into various activities that
were going on in the park we can
speculate that the park as it existed in
the first half of the 1930s became a
miniature socialist utopia at least in
the architects projects it served as a
model for an ideal socialist urban
settlement in which not only was
recreation collectivized but the
organization of space also mimic the
principles of left social urban planning
for example in such aspects as the
separation of activities and the
reconciliation of nature and the city by
turning nature
into a metrics for urban pastimes
divided into such zones as the mass
participation zone the sports zone the
scientific zone and so on the park
supposedly optimized the use of a
visitor's time in satisfying his or her
recreational needs most of the
activities allowed for the visitors of
the park where of a special kind
collective and highly programmatic they
left no possibility for individual or
family recreation and no freedom of
choice mass processions demonstrations
meetings concepts and sports games were
regularly imposed ways of spending ones
time in the park these activities were
intended to form a new subject of the
new society the masses as opposed to the
old individual and group subjects to
accommodate these activities the usual
park lawns and shaded pathways had to
give way to broad avenues in spacious
open grounds I believe that this
emphasis on collectivity together with
the ideological propaganda from which it
was inseparable became the most
characteristic feature of the park of
culture and rest during the first years
of its existence another interpretation
of the parks as the site of subject
formation this time intended to produce
individual subjects was suggested in
1935 when a group of psychologists led
by one of the fathers of Soviet
psychology aleksey nikolayevich leroy
native conducted a series of thorough
psychological observations and
experiments in the Central Park of
culture and rest the goal of their
research which was most likely
commissioned by the director of the park
beta glenn was first to determine how
people actually spend their time in the
park and what extent the park fulfilled
the intentions and desires and second to
suggest the ways of modifying this
behavior in these intentions through
reconfiguring the design of the whole
park and its particular sectors leontief
suggested
Epicurus psychological model of the soul
called Gordon called vertical principle
of exposition which unfolds from the
most striking and attractive towards
deeper and more intellectually
challenging exhibits quoting their
director BTW glance words he suggested a
move quote from accordion and guitar too
sophisticated Symphony music from
amateur agitation Brigade too grandiose
performances at the masque theatre from
a popular movie lecture to a serious
scholarly talk unquote the ultimate goal
of this movement for Glenn and Leo
native was to develop a quote
Polytechnic person that is in use of its
subject who has a broad range of
interests and wider edition in the
fields important for the industrializing
country physics technology engineering
aviation new methods of agriculture and
so on and this March for their utopia in
projects and now I turn to deborah's a
reality with which they were confronted
and here you can see a dancing round
from the 1970s and a cafe in the Minsk
park or which also was titled Gorky Park
as all of them seem to be in 1939 the
evidence from the period demonstrates
that this sophisticated ideological
program remains ignored by the visitors
to Soviet parts as opposed to a
complicated plan of a typical early Park
of culture and rest with the stages
museums and culture palaces a subjective
map of a usual user was in fact read
used to an early connecting the entrance
to the dancin area with kiosks selling
drinks and benches alongside this le
here is for example a quotation from a
memoir of a regular Soviet Park user
which describes the events of the mid
1930s when he was a teenager and in
which elements from the propagandistic
program are perceived within the vision
of a park of culture and dressed
as an entirely recreational space the
action takes place in hiked up one of
the largest cities in southern Russia
and our part of Ukraine and this park
also Gorky Park is one of over 2,000
parts of culture and rest created in the
USSR by the mid-1950s and i quote nor
arkasha needa Eska and these are two
boys names none of them had bicycles so
Yvonne and I were biking mostly during
the daytime and in the evenings the
whole company would go strolling into
the park now our company of Musketeers
was joined by two girls from our class
at that time Gorky Park was very popular
with hot cups residence and on weekends
and in the evenings it attracted crowds
of the strolling public it had
everything that one could wish for rest
to dancing grounds green theater summer
movie theater laughs and pavilion
labyrinth of distortion mirrors concert
stages and even a parachute tower there
was an entrance charge only in the
evenings when the artists were
performing on the concert stages the
entrance was only 25 Corp X but were
still saving money and having bought
tickets for the girls infiltrated
through the holes in the fences or
entered from the park's backside which
lacked a fence at the end of the Central
Park Ellie there was a dancing ground
where the brass band played here
everybody could dance they were in
charge an additional fees for it the
second dancing ground was located in the
heart of the park jazz was played there
and the entrance was not free it had a
nice stage projectors and Catalans of
colored light bulbs but we would really
go there this was the place for elite
youth which could not only pay for
everything but also dress well sometimes
when I happened to be nearby I enviously
watched the gaudy crowd swirling with
jazz sounds and thought
what are these people where do they come
from after all the FEMEN just ended
can't quote the memories keeps in memory
such spaces as the green theater summer
movie theater concert stages and a
parachute tower which could have
appeared in the park as a means for
propaganda and mass work but later we're
envisioned as purely recreational spaces
alongside with such facilities as
dancing grounds and dillivan pavilion
for him the park was primarily a space
for dancing in the company of his
friends and the members suggests no
indication of any self identification
with the math subject all the
consumption of any ideological
propaganda by the author instead
traditional forms of socializing and
recreation have reclaimed the space in
the city's public park by the mid-1930s
it became clear to Stalin's
administration that the visitors were
silently sabotaging the propagandistic
mission of the park of culture and
dressed merova contrary to the cliche
image of a totalitarian state system the
bureaucrats not only accepted this fact
but also started searching for a new
design solution that will take into
account the habits and desires of the
public already in 1933 the parks were
told to quote turn towards achieve full
gay and amusing recreation about in 1936
well-known satirical writers if and
Petrov wrote a satire in the central
newspaper Pravda in which they walk in
the previously dominant mass
participation program depicted the
plight of a man who came to the park of
culture and rest but was not permitted
to go his own way in the story every
time the young man would come into the
park with a girlfriend and was looking
for a secluded spot in which to sit on
the grass with her a group of activists
would grab them by their hands and force
them to dance
likewise they're psychologists attempts
to transform the park into an
institution that changes personality and
a result the visitors behavior were
rejected by the party in 1937 of the
director beta glant was subjected to
political repression and up to that date
no new experimental solutions were
suggested cut right in Gorky Park it is
revealing that post-war publications
which site Lyon tips research quote only
those aspects of page that concern the
actual figures of the distribution of
the visitors with in the parks sectors
the idea of modifying people's
intentions and desires of making the
park at birthplace of a new subject was
left aside instead the party wanted to
use this space for satisfying the
existent needs and desires of the people
which were previously considered
undeveloped and blow by the oven god
architects and psychologists if we
wanted the fact that only a minority of
the visitors were interested in the
village of science and technology was a
beautiful situation that had to be
corrected for the post-world war two
sociologist and park managers this was
the expression of the wheel of the
people that had to be respected and
Asajj SATs illogical research in the
park was resumed up to the wall and now
I turned to the the parks layout as it
was developed by the state in response
to people's desires according to the
post work books and manuals the two
major desires that had to be satisfied
by the works of culture and rest were to
quote stroll and to visit attractions
both of them were purely recreational
and had nothing to do with the parks
previous educational and propagandistic
program the satisfaction of these two
desires became the core goal of all
parks of culture and dressed in the
second half of the 1940s and persisted
as
hush until the collapse of the Soviet
Union even in spite of the disfavor of
Stalin's principles in architecture in
city planning that followed in the late
1950s I believe that it was precisely
the formal indeterminacy of parks of
culture and dressed and they need
functionalism of their concept that is
the fact that they were defined in terms
of functional program rather than style
that allowed the steadiest concept to
become a part of brochures and latent
Brezhnev's modernism the first of these
two components of the simple functional
program of the post-war parks of culture
and rest was strolling this component
generated a large number of paths and
routes that we entered through the park
it was also economically easy to achieve
since in most cases parks of culture and
rest were created in woodlands or in the
sides of pre-existing aristocratic
estates always wide enough to allow a
group of people to pass and supplemented
with benches these paths became
convenient spaces for slow leisurely
group movement and conversations as well
quiet rest and here you can see one of
those paths in a publication from 1935
that is from Moscow Sequoia Linkin Park
pictured empty of people and it's very
similar paths in Moscow Gorky Park
actually photographed by angry
cartier-bresson in 1954 the next
component attractions were attributed
for children as well as for adults and
included observation wheel wills swings
and so on if in the first postwar years
the attractions were mostly improvised
and easy to build such as those that you
can see top left from a 19th otis
publication then gradually and
especially in the sixties and seventies
they became replaced by industrially
produced standardized attractions
dancing grounds and performance areas
to where a necessary part of every part
of culture and rest throughout the u.s.
Assad period this race of spending ones
time in a park reflected traditional
peasant ways of recreation which became
dominant in the Soviet cities in the
aftermath of Stalin's urbanization
peasants habits their ways of spending
the leisure time in the approach a 'ok
added you to nature were brought by them
to the perks of culture and rest where
they soon became acknowledged by the
state and this acknowledgment allowed
for the consolidation of the type of
public park that persisted in the USSR
from the 1940s until its collapse in the
late 80s when when it was exported to
the other countries of the soviet bloc
merova it seems that sin Stalin's death
the cultural and educational component
of the park being least popular was
steadily declining and almost totally
disappeared towards the end of the
Soviet rule in spite of the continuing
use of the park of culture and rest
title being neither a space for
unification with nature which will be a
normal program for a 19th century
metropolitan pastoral park no aside for
mass activities and propaganda which was
the initial architects agenda of the
park nor a place for education and
intellectual development which was the
psychologist approach but fooling the
people's desires the park became a place
for group recreation strollin visiting
attractions gathering and dancin the use
of sociological data and the
consideration of the mass visitors
intentions and desires in order to
determine the ways of the modification
of the parks program and design makes
part of culture and rest it truly
people's park at least to the extent
this term can be applied to Stalin's
totalitarian
xiety the acknowledgment of this fact
and does with agency the subjects of the
totalitarian state which are usually
considered to be totally silenced merova
we can see that this agency was offered
to them by none other than the state
itself conforming to the so-called
revisionist School of Soviet history
ography which is interested in the
support of Stalin system from below the
case of the usage of sociological data
for the park of culture and rest in
Moscow suggests that the state for its
part was actively seeking for this
support thank you
great well first of all I want to thank
all the organizers for this flawless and
enormous event I can't imagine how much
work looked into it and also the and the
other members of the panel who've I
think have set up a lot of ideas that we
can talk about so with that I think I'll
just begin if I can figure out how this
works in late nineteen sixty eight the
right are you ready pollution visited a
nearly complete experimental housing
complex known as quarter number ten in
Moscow's rapidly developing novia to do
miss key district the dome level babita
the house of the new way of life was the
highlight of his trip designed by Nathan
Osterman and a team of architects
engineers and social scientists the
building's name conveyed its social
transformative function more than inert
matter the dome of the beta was a
fundamentally political project a
blueprint for a new collective way of
life for polluting the project's
ambition represented more than a utopian
vision it was in his words not a fantasy
but a reality since the death of Joseph
Stalin in 1953 Nikita and Nikita
Khrushchev's ascent to the summit of
Soviet power novia children whiskey had
become according to polluting a place
where quote many designs for the future
had been reborn and quote this district
condensed the aspirations of Soviet
architectures post Stalinist paradigm
novia tree domes he's widely publicized
quarter number nine presented a steer
concrete panel building said in a
verdant landscape as a model for the
Soviet resident for Soviet residential
architecture a model that was anti
monument an onion aunty monumental and
cleansed of what crew show of called
formal excess also designed by a team
led by Austin man this looked like the
fulfillment of Khrushchev's promise of
housing for all Soviet citizens
polluting saw a quarter number 10 and
the house of the new way of life as a
direct descendant of this post Stalinist
approach to architecture and residential
design he celebrated the building's
complex program in this report for the
Lutheran
the literary newspaper which sent him
you know on a site visit quote 216 story
residential slabs gaze upon the social
center he wrote quote the first stories
are not residential but given over to a
club service quarters play rooms for
children the slabs are linked by a
heated glazed vestibule into in a
two-story social center that has
everything beginning with a large cafe a
swimming pool a winter garden and ending
with a Finnish sauna a dry cleaner and a
barber but looking tried to maintain a
degree of skepticism about the building
but had little success I'm sorry each
apartment was fully furnished and
residents would have access to
appliances such as sewing machines and
vacuums through a central loan office it
seemed like the architects had
anticipated the future tenants every
need except palookie noted the need for
a kitchen each small apartment resembled
a well and extended stay hotel room
having a full bathroom but only a
cooking nook with two electric stove
plates in a sink in place of private
kitchens each floor of the residential
slabs has both the cafe and a large
shared kitchen communal dining
compensated for the reduction of private
utilities in each of the building 16
floors contained a shared study
expanding the amount of space available
to each tenant quote a collective will
live in this building complex and this
determines everything polluting observed
noting that a different psychological
atmosphere will be created here but
looking touched upon the ultimate
political ambition of the team of
architects engineers sociologist and
economist who had designed the building
and established its program namely to
create a socially transformative
atmosphere which would turn atomized an
atomized group of tenants into a
collective another comment another
commentator on the building the
venerable economists tennis of stew
Molina redoubled pollutants observations
writing that the building quote creates
optimal conditions for the successful
formation of the norms and regulations
of the Communist way of life in this the
house of the new way of life registers a
complex and deliberate response to the
revised program of the Communist Party
of the Soviet Union that krutov had
presented at
20 second party congress in 1961 at this
event the Soviet premier declared that
quote we shall in the main have built a
communist society within 20 years
Kershaw have predicted that the USSR's
transition to communism would be
achieved by quote improving and
developing social relations with due
amount with with you account of the
disappearance of old forms of life and
the appearance of new forms in quote the
house of the new way of life gave
architectural form to the Communist
Party's predictions it was an attempt to
materialize the social and ideological
mission of the Soviet state to create a
space that might both embody new forms
of social organization and become a
mechanism for the creation of a new way
of life this response to crucial
assertion of communism nascent state
until the recovery of several important
aspects of Soviet architectures
disciplinary profile most importantly
the rediscovery of the revolutionary
social mission advanced by Soviet
architects during the 1920s and more
broadly a belief in the social agency of
architecture since the beginning of the
1960's architects and historians in both
the Soviet Union and the West had begun
to look at what had come had been called
the quote heroic age of modern
architecture with new eyes the house of
the new way of life articulates the
survival of modernism's legacy as an
architectural projection of the imminent
arrival of communism in the Soviet Union
and although the ambitions of the
building were transformative the
building's designers viewed the project
not in opposition to the aims of the
Soviet state but as a possible future
for communist societies spatial
articulation that is as a microcosm of a
communist self of communist
self-organization and governance as such
the house of the new way of life
reframes the relationship that's at the
center of this conference it asked us to
consider not only architecture and the
state but also architecture as the state
nearly 10 years separate the conception
and completion of the house of the new
way of life between 1962 when the first
project appeared in 1971 when the first
tenants moved in the cultural politics
of Soviet architecture underwent a rapid
transformations the first few years of
the building's design and construction
correspond to the period now widely
associated with Ilya Ehrenburg famous
description of the years of
de-stalinization has the thaw the decade
between 1954 when crucial with
Khrushchev's rise to power within the
Communist Party witnessed a relative
liberalisation of cultural restrictions
in a variety of creative fields by the
time the house of the new way of life
was completed the only operation of had
succeeded Khrushchev as leader of the
Communist Party transforming the
optimism of the thaw into a social and
cultural stasis that came to be known as
stagnation now's the new way of life
stands between these two moments regice
regice Turing both the renewed sense of
social agency that architects
experienced during the thaw and the
frustration of collective agency in the
twilight of late socialism architecture
and construction were among the first
disciplines to experience the effects of
de-stalinization in a now famous speech
delivered at a conference of architects
and builders in 1954 crucial of
denounced the so-called formal excess
characteristic postwar architecture and
called for the introduction of
industrial methods in all spheres of
construction he challenged the notion
that had emerged during the era of high
Stalinism that formal excess could be
justified as an antidote to
constructivism although he stopped short
of a call for a revival of constructor
constructivist principles crucial
nevertheless advocated a shift toward
frankly industrial design and made mass
production in architectural ideal
although soviet architects had already
experimented with systems of
prefabrication for nearly 20 20 years
who shows speech provided new impetus
for the building industry to make
industrial the industrialization of
construction and priority particularly
in the field of residential design novia
cheerio muskies quarter number nine
designed constructed between 1956 and
1957 encapsulated the transformation of
artificial priorities in the first years
of the thaw Austin and his team of
architects coordinated apartment houses
shops schools cinema and other
facilities on this 12 hectare site
presenting muscovites with a vision have
dramatically improved living conditions
well shared apartments represented the
stand
for non-elite housing in Moscow novia
trio mrs. quarter number nine sought to
provide families with private two and
three-bedroom apartments the development
suggested that signify that dignified
living conditions for average Soviet
citizens might be achieved through the
rapid development of the building
industry the success of quarter of
number nine facilitated the construction
of a second experimental housing
district in Nova chido mesquite quarter
number ten the district's unimaginative
name belies the radical reformation of
Soviet architecture social agency that
is embedded within the project designed
by Osterman the house of the new way of
life was the most innovative element of
this new quarter this building differed
from his previous residential design in
a critical way whereas the buildings of
quarter number nine sought to provide
private accommodations to each household
the house of the new way of life
questioned the validity of the family
unit as a basic as the basis for
residential design Austin and his
colleagues understood the house of the
new way of life as a reprise of the
damaja mooney or communal houses that
soviet architects had developed in the
1920s and 1930s the nark on Fein
building designed by morsy Ginsburg and
even Ivan Nikolayevich doma Tori for
students of Moscow's textile institute
each of which sacrificed private space
for the expansion of collective
facilities served as the primary points
of reference for the program of the
house of the new way of life quote the
general idea of the organization of a
collective way of life and the
liberation of women from housework
brings the building closer to earlier
projects Osterman concluded the
commitment of the building's designers
to strength to transform the lives of
the building's tenants recalls Ginsburg
statement of 1927 that constructivism
presents the architect with quote the
task of life building of the
organization of new forms of life end
quote architecture in both Osterman's
and Ginsberg estimation possessed the
power to transform everyday reality to
induce the formation of new social
relations by 1965 when Austin Milan and
his colleagues had articulated the
program of the house of the new way of
life the legacy of constructivism hadri
emerged as a topic for historical
discussion both within the Soviet Union
and
in the West whereas constructivism had
been called a reactionary bourgeois
ideology in the final years of Stalin's
rain it had become a popular subject of
research and a facet of contemporary
debate in the USSR the writer Victor
Nekrasov was among the first to suggest
that constructivism was not only a
historical interest but that the lessons
of constructivist architecture might
have some bearing on the contemporary on
the contemporary moment in the early
1960s the prolific historian Salem Han
magomayev authored the landmark pioneers
of Soviet architecture the unpublishing
his first articles on moisa Ginsberg and
even layer need of the legacy of
constructivism was published in the West
primarily through architectural journals
in a landmark issue of 1962 of Casa
Bella continuity shown here the history
of Soviet architecture was brought to a
Western audience and a powerful graphic
survey shortly thereafter George
scandalous would describe what he called
the heroic moment of modern architecture
in the USSR in an encyclopedic issue of
logitech to the job we of 1964 and
finally well not finally but in
succession Allison and Peter's Peter
Smithson would fold the history of
Soviet modernism into their survey of
the heroic period of modern architecture
for the British Journal architectural
design in 1965 Austin Moon's project for
the house of the new way of life emerged
from this general revival of interest in
art in the architecture of
constructivism but the building had more
than a superficial relationship to the
radical projects of the 1920s among the
many social scientists that estimate and
his team consulted with during the
building's design was the Economist
stanislav strimling whose contributions
to soviet economics date back to the
1920s at that time streaming emerges a
strong supporter of the collective a
collectivization of everyday life during
the years of the first five-year plan
that is from nineteen twenty eight to
nineteen thirty two he argued that the
socialist city should be built upon a
network of social services that would
achieve an economy of scale by
substituting collective services for
individual labor removing activities
such as cooking and cleaning from the
private sphere we both helped women
enter the workforce and stimulate a new
network
of social bonds among Soviet citizens in
the early 1960s sternly return to the
topic of collective the collectivization
of everyday life articulating his ideas
in the context of Khrushchev's
optimistic prediction that the Soviet
Union would achieve communism by 1980 in
communism in the lives of workers a
widely circulated essay of nineteen
sixty he offered an architectural
prediction of the USSR's transition to a
higher stage of Social Development he
described quote c-come looming communal
palaces for up to twenty five hundred
residents these buildings like the
communal houses devised by soviet
architects during the 1920s were to
include cafeterias laundromats shared
study rooms and sports halls for the
inhabitants although the spatial model
that strimling described here was not
knew that it could attract serious
consideration was unprecedented the
collective reorganization of everyday
life had had in fact been a taboo topic
in Soviet Union since 1930 when the
Communist Party issued a decree that put
an end to the quote semi fantastical
architectural projects that sought to
construct communist social relations
quote in one leap this decree frustrated
architects plans to make communal houses
the fundamental unit of in the
reconstruction of socialist cities and
place the organization of everyday life
beyond the scope of architectures
disciplinary concerns guided by
streaming liens recommendations the
authors of the new of the house of the
new way of life sought to recover both
the form of the communal house and the
social mission which it contained
whereas the primary forces of novia
charities quarter number nine had been
the family unit the house of the new way
of life highlighted the importance of
the collective the reduced sizes and
facilities within individual apartments
encourage residents to participate in
communal dining and recreation the
notion of living space was dispersed
throughout the many shared areas of the
complex but the dispersal of living
space alone was not sufficient to
encourage collective atmosphere within
the house of the new way of life the
building's designers went a step further
than their constructivist predecessors
in articulating in addition to a special
program
grant for social for the social
organization of the tenants Osterman
called this the quote union of the house
of the new way of life the union was to
be a legal entity which would obtain a
degree of autonomy by effectively
renting the building and its territory
from the state the organization's
primary task was quote to combine
collective and individual forms of
organization with the aim of forming a
communist world view among its members
and quote Osterman and his colleagues
outlined a complex organizational
structure for the Union describing the
process of collective decision-making
administration conflict resolution with
numerous feedback loops between
individual tenants and landlords ease
the union was designed to function not
as a rigid hierarchy but as a democratic
organism as a body composed of all
tenants of the house of the new way of
life the union representative commitment
to collective living it structure fused
individuals into a larger social body
that is the house of the new way of life
which was both a residential structure
and a structure of governance for the
building's designer these two aspects of
the project were inseparable the model
of coming his self organization that the
designers at the house of the new way of
life created was not simply a tool to
administer and sips and sustain a
residential collective composed of more
than 2,000 people it was an attempt to
create a microcosm of the Soviet Union's
imminent communist future the house of
the new way of life approximated
streaming liam's description of the
communal of communal palaces as future
units in a quote system of
self-governing organizations end quote
the building wasn't was an attempt to
condense and realize a model of the
highly organized society of free
socially conscious working people that
the Communist Party predicted the Soviet
Union would become although early
visitors to the to the building were
deeply impressed by the social mission
of the house the new way of life the
building had little chance to perform
its function perform the functions with
which was invested but the time
construction was completed in 1971 the
optimism characteristic of Khrushchev's
star had given way to the perpetual
Twilight of Brezhnev stagnation the
program of the house of the new way of
life shifted along with Moscow's
cultural climate ultimately becoming a
dormitory for the Moscow State
University
it's tempting to see this conflation of
residential program in communist
self-governance that lies at the heart
of the house of any way of life as a
utopian proposition but it should be
borne in mind that the observers such as
UD caloocan the writer with huma began
to other project quote not as a fantasy
but as a reality that is as a fragment
of a potentially obtainable communist
future in which architectural design and
organized self-governance might become
indistinguishable thank
or rather when I really wanna says and
the reason I was saying that I really am
happy that this panel is existing within
this conference is that it actually is
helping me think through the things that
I am already thinking through now I
don't want to repeat to your papers or
recap them in any way but for me a few
big issues that are that you know have
been through that I've been trying to
deal with personally that I think your
papers bring up my goat or a series of
things that are like the position of the
architect in this context the the sort
of status of statements made in this
context and maybe the relationship to
the avant-garde and the later years
which you all in a way to pick up but so
the first question that I wanted to ask
y'all is that and I think you it already
gets a little bit addressed through that
sort of explanation of avant-garde and
what comes later or the position of it
or the historic sizing I wait and so
forth but for me what struck me is that
even though we have a kind of situation
where the position of the architect in
this context the state architect human
is different than the norm in terms of
writing history basically there are
figures that emerged in each of your
papers as specific figures in greg's
basically the figure of hop in Riggs the
figure of Osterman and in olives not so
much actually the figure of the
architect but the the picture that we
saw would be the figure of sociologists
nor the psychologist in this case but so
for me I'm wondering how we can whether
in some way the kind of the change in
the position of the architect and the
particular relationship of the
architects to the state whether they are
the state
the question but like how does that in a
way and does an impact for you the very
structure of the narratives that you
create highly so so I'm going to go all
of my questions we'll go basically to
the kind of what is our theory of the
second world history so that how do you
what's your position on this well I'll
just start in terms of the emergence of
Hans Hulk it in many ways is not at all
surprising that a specific a specific
figure emerges you have a society in a
fairly dramatic process of social social
reconstruction there because we
understand as these Germans search
driven party members who are governing
that there needs to be that the Soviet
solution of society is a solution it's a
global communist system that's their own
words I'm not inventing that term so
essentially the USSR is the paradigm the
Stalinist system in the USSR has already
developed a system in which there will
be different portions of society from
structure of society and one part of
society is a model worker the worker one
is in inteligencia it will be in a
creative intelligentsia so if there is
going to be creative intelligentsia
which incidentally may be paid ten times
more than a worker so it's a very well
remunerated group someone has to someone
has to be a murdered someone has to
emerge as a model so there's going to be
somebody who plays that role it could be
Hans Hans hope it could be some other
person but someone will emerge as an
intelligent in the system so in this
particular case the fact he is
add the Academy plays a role in
somewhere I mean he could not be that
figure if he were not the leader of a
bow Academy master studio that's by
definition who is which for me
implicates then issue or the entire sore
layer of the pedagogical institutions
involved in in between that sort of
relationship between architects and
state firms and state directives at this
particular moment the bow Academy is
formed in 1951 there's no educational
system that is in place to produce these
figures so they have to emerge as
incarnations really the social order so
somebody's going to do it and this and
in a sense it for these architects it's
not really the creation of a kind of
math subject this is a subjectivity and
somebody assembles a subjectivity from
elements that are there for them to do
this and one has to keep in mind at East
Berlin is a very interesting case study
because an architect could simply walk
across to the west I mean just you could
just walk out of the system and somebody
like console or Herman hanselman did not
do that they stayed and became model
architects I think in my case a part for
Luanne's if who was as I mentioned a
psychologist and who was employed by the
state to conduct his research there are
also a number of other people such as
their architects from i started with
gains work and magic of our mannequins
officially the director of the park not
the director but they have had architect
for a while as mostly tsk and there was
very important person beta glam of their
director and all of them were in a very
complicated relationship with the state
on the part of the architects I don't
think there was any opposition of them
to the state they were trying to get the
intentions they were trying to grasp
what the state
was from them and that was evident in
all the entries for the 1931 competition
and then glam of their director was a
state employee at at the same time she
was patronizing this innovative
psychological research it was
patronizing on the work of Ellen good
architects and at the same time she was
hoping from from what I understand she
was hoping that this is precisely what
the state wants she would by no means be
try to perceive herself as an
oppositional figure and the same for new
ownership who just who was trying to
conduct the research started by the
state sponsored laboratory if I can just
find I think the implication of your
question are much larger you know the
kind of mythological nature and the
things that I've been trying to struggle
with as well because it I mean the
question I think you're essentially
asking is what we what do we think about
authorship and why use biography as the
narrative for what what we're doing here
when we know we're dealing with
societies that are barely you know have
very very intense set of rigidly
organized social structures and one you
know on the one hand it's it looks like
perhaps a the easy way out you have to
find you know to find the figure and
follow him or her or no one idea and
trace it through these you know the span
of a career something but I guess one of
the reasons to that I started to look at
individuals within this
kind of second world context is because
as well actually as a way to understand
institutions because institutions
particularly with Osterman and you know
any number of figures at least in the
soviet soviet context I find are
constantly being renovated and
reformulated and the the kind of the
bureaucracy is not stable is and so by
looking at one person as a kind of
narrative thread you can actually reveal
the the changes are deemed to be
instabilities within these these
institutions for example Osterman who
highlighted today designed you know
quarters nine and ten under the auspices
of different institutions but he was
doing more or less the same kind of work
and working with the same kind of people
so there's there's there are
continuities as well you know within
this kind of chaotic and but what I
thought what I see is being a
fundamentally unstable bureaucratic
apparatus I mean I that's exactly going
towards that to see why do we rely on
the biographical narrative or the usual
sort of even that avant-garde narrative
in order to tell the stories of the
context in which an avant-garde as
institution as a position is no longer
available at least rhetorically and so
in Greg's case it sounds like actually
there is a version of Vanguard or at
least and in well certainly kind of
intelligentsia there is not a social
but I also do think you know the I mean
certainly having in a writing on this
topic the kind of track price is that
who do you follow do you follow an
object discussion or subject is a
serious one and a methodological serious
methodological question one where I do
agree that basically part of the strange
dance between the directives the
officials and the architects is going to
be played out through particular
subjects rather than somehow on mass
even if they in the end sort of produce
a pattern of behavior forth but so
related to that I just wanted to add
something that lecture what might the
whole point of my presentation was it
was an attempt to get away from this
idea of the NARC attacked as the subject
yes as the subject of what is of the
design and turned 22 trying to grasp
this invisible mass of Ages camassia
collective agent of the people as more
actual subject I mean so along the same
lines basically and again like
self-serving you know when I write about
this stuff I often find myself wanting
to put quotes around my own statements
about the work and and so for me I want
to sort of talk about maybe the status
of statement that you find in an archive
and how do you deal with them because
because in a way a directive is
different than a specific client
requests and so from the outset the kind
of response that the architects are
involved in producing is one of a kind
of a stranger a different interpretation
than we're again used to in
architectural history so how do you
evaluate you
or maybe there's evidence evidentiary
dilemma if I can respond again I mean
that's for me that this kind of problem
between directive and respondents and
execution is part of this instability
that that I'm trying to highlight that
yes I mean as as documents these
directive has a different status and
trying to try to work out what that
status is is a complicated process but
this is one of the reason this is one of
the reasons why i think it's it's
interesting at least two tests yeah as a
kind of experiment you know what did a
number of different subjects a number of
different individuals do in response to
a directive you know how and so for that
reason like being very precise and
looking at this problem with biography
and really individual agency the agency
of the architect or the team of
architects in responding to say the
director that you know the modernism is
not satisfactory for example or that
excess is no longer valid you know
there's a range of positions and I think
they're still yet to be explored but i
think i would probably support the idea
that there are different these
directives and these statements do
occupy a particular furthermore the we
talked about intentional limit in the
last panel but the idea that when you
get an architect describing their
intention in a journal so forth it's
always like how you treat that is a
really specific question it goes beyond
even sort of looking at the particular
product that comes out of their
interpretation
and the rest of the dance but sort of
what is a statement what is the value of
that statement even I think is a
question for me it was important to
think about how this director directives
are changeable how they are in stable
how they contradict each other and try
to understand who's behind them and why
are they so and so whichever particular
moment of history and it was rather was
a statement whose directives are they
may be rather than how do they work and
what is the mechanism of control well in
my city this is like one case study of a
number of architects i agree with Ricky
that essentially you look at a number of
people and how they respond to these
directives and just as a sort of to
encapsulate it martes tom was teaching
at the design school at Berlin bison say
he came they came down on him of this
new kind of cultural revolution he tried
to find a compromise with modernism he
was put under house arrest within a year
he was in exile so essentially that's
the other possible response but also in
terms of reading this article and trying
to read what into what does hop mean
when he says this thing that you know my
modern design can progress can have a
process of design development that ends
up making it any a passable design
that's why I actually firmly believe
that you have to take ideology seriously
you have to look at it and so for me the
parallel between child development
developmental psychology ideology really
was the only thing that I could start to
make that proposition design proposition
makes sense to me I mean I mean I've
encountered many of the tropes I'm sure
that's the thing that
is that you've all basically described
but this one particular one of how sort
of developmental notion of socialist
realism comes as a natural conclusion
here of sorts which I think actually
allows them the next step off so that
actually let us rework it a little bit
and now it's going to look different
after cru strips so close to even though
he sounds like a break actually it's
just a step on top of that yeah can I
ask you questions in responses and he
said i think what what's always floating
behind these statements and i think some
of your line of questioning is really
the question of commitment and the
status of these directives and we're
talking about control and the question
is you know why would you do this you
know why would architects actually make
these statements why would they why
would they not try to update in some
ways and not a thats not necessarily an
option but I feel like that's kind of
what I mean for me the questions are
actually on our love at this table it's
like how do we deal with this fact but i
think you know in the in the second what
what all of these contexts shares that
there is no way out this is the
situation so then how do you you know
clearly they're having to find ways to
work within it but the sort of the
development from story for me is it is
important i think it is actually
something that talks about the kind
socialism timeline or relationship to
time before it but i would just clarify
one thing from my perspective there's a
profound break at the moment of
Khrushchev in a sense that is the RT is
infallible it's like the Pope says women
cannot play certain roles in the church
and then tomorrow the Pope would say oh
by the way the church made a little
error women can actually do this it's
suddenly
the notion of infallibility and I think
that's a really profound moment in this
cruise ship transformation I mean I I
think so too in some sense but I also
think it's a it's one of those things
where basically that those couple of
speeches the secret and the one to the
builders don't fundamentally change
anything it's just like the secret
speech sort of erase is supposedly the
tyrant from the Stalinist system without
actually changing the system the erasure
of socialist realism from socialist
realism doesn't actually change the
system so there's I mean I think there's
a break in in a kind of reading of it
and yet I kind of insurance that there
is continuity because socialism is
continues just like you very kind of
continuity within its logic but there
was a Stalinist purge of the
architectural profession with minor
minor consequences so people didn't get
into camps but Khrushchev 2d Stalin eyes
architecture conducted a kind of
Stalinist purge so in a sense that's a
consciously pop pop just slides right
through is she does fine but that's a
mostly Soviet phenomenon the purge of
social Surrealists I just wanted to add
about the developmental thing that what
was also at stake with the this ideas of
progressive development of architecture
it was what was interesting that it's
parallel deities of the development of
the development of society as such and
Stalin is reportedly have said to write
for example that i'm not against
modernism i just think that at our stage
of the development of economic base we
are not ready for it yet but believe me
in 10 years we will have modernist so
basically we can think that what pro
chef is doing he is just arriving at
arrival at that pool
then we the break would be not such
radical but who's the author of that I
mean where do you know that statement
from is that a quote from right well yes
honey that's when we got to the I just
had a thought that but yeah I actually
the thing about where we lasted I wanted
to maybe ask you big about the notion of
beauty because i think it appears in
these different context differently
certainly in the czech context it's
theirs synthesis harmony and things like
that then they extend beyond 5456 and to
ask to be the program aesthetically well
for me if you want look at so honest
architecture socialist realism you have
to take ideology seriously beauty is a
part of ideology the confusing thing for
us is we have a word in our language
called beauty and it means certain
things and it's also pretty vague and so
that's a different thing i mean we have
a word for eclecticism in the psalmist
look adler there is something called
eclecticism and it means something
really different so it's very confusing
and one has to go back to basic terms
and try to develop a kind of culturally
specific understanding of what that
thing is and i tried to basically give a
little gloss about what beauty was when
i want to open it to the audience I
could keep doing
my question is for Greg and Allah both
in the concept of beauty and a popular
mass enjoyment recreation there is a
sense of reaching the people and
mediated Lee and but at the same time I
think there is still a sense of
reaeration as comes out for the notion
of beauty that doesn't come as an
intuitive creative process but a
rational creative process that allows
you to reach this unmediated moment of
beauty that will speak to the to the
working class so I was wondering if
there is if you see this ambiguity also
in the recreational parks Allah and what
is your take about this ambiguity in
there in hopes work or his ideas of
Education well education was not
precisely what i was thinking about so
my take on it was getting away from the
educational agenda and yeah I understand
your challenge of my position but I
think that what they were doing in this
particular example of public space were
just given a little space for people to
do what they want when in the situation
when they couldn't throw out the rest of
their lives basically I mean to do what
they want within certain extent of
course but it's it's a relief place I
think yeah I I yeah I don't I think
I saw it related to well I like the
argument of the paper you know people
are somehow people's daily life is
somehow taken into account actually
maybe even in that your trajectory of
the paper they want or they are winning
against the education agenda I also
think there's an aspect to that like
happiness and satisfaction of the mass
is that this particular point are proof
that the system works and so I think
that is actually really important just
like we have arrived that the new way of
life or at least we finally meet the new
way of life because feminism is imminent
yeah I don't feel that I mean in
ideological terms i think there's fairly
that's there's very little that's
unmediated in socialist realist beauty
so you bet your essential phrase I think
comes from a kind of a Western
understanding beauty that you arrive at
an unmediated moment it's not that's how
it's going to work because I mean beauty
becomes very heavy I heavily ideologist
to get ideology wrong is like a fairly
big problem so you know somebody could
go in and say like but you know
constructivism that's beautiful no
constructivism is absolutely not
beautiful so beautiful what the
beautiful is is very very heavily this
is the point where you're the point the
period that you're describing would be
the period where Stalin is requesting
all works to be socialists in content
and national inform and so national
inform would have to be what is
beautiful whatever that is well but
that's also one of the problems is that
there's an ideology it has to be social
from Beauty and national and for us of
whatever the thing is what is
nationalist and form and then architects
are trying to you know come up with
solutions as you said that they were
trying to understand the first part what
is it that was one
from that program and that's one of the
problems you have an ideology that
demands very specific solutions but as a
creative you don't know what they are
yet and so you're trying to invent what
that is can I just kind of follow up on
that in some of the work that i'm trying
to do interesting these questions that
you know as a producer as an author you
don't know what to do I mean I'm trying
to come to the terms the idea that
ambiguity is structurally that this is
part fundamentally part of the project
until we can accept that possibility
we're going to be reeling from the rapid
shifts and instability of this kind of
aesthetic ideological regime that's
did stalin use the park did he have a go
was he taking photo ops and the reason
I'm saying this the our head of state
from 32 to 45 he's in a wheelchair he's
not walking anywhere but he's followed
by Truman 45 to 50 to he's walking
everywhere he's getting up and walking
he's he said does that affect down where
he's in his doctor he's in his Kremlin
he's not going anywhere in the public
sometimes yes park of corruption dress
was a very important place for for
establishing the connection between the
power and the people I was actually the
other part of my research that I was
looking at is how do they always get
this feedback from the people how do
they know that the people actually want
and then Park of culture and dress was a
very important space for that because
there would be mass processions but not
much as processions but meetings of the
people with writers poets intelligence'
and also the party members when they
would have open conversations about
their life yeah can I ask a follow-up
question today I think you raise a lot
of wrenching issues but i wonder what
the relationship between the park of
culture and relaxation is to its other
northern on ludic space of red square of
the highly formalized ritual public
space saying how do you negotiate that
pair of public events in first projects
I think it was even determined by the
program that they have to be connected
because they are quite near
geographically it's maybe like three
kilometers of something so initially
there had to be a major in my leg still
in LA
like big very big fences Street
connecting the two that would also be
space for demonstrations from there a
square combination in the park of
calcium dress which eventually was not
realized but that was the idea we have
time only for one more question I have a
question to Charles the figure of
Osterman in a sense united together two
strands of a revival of modernist
architecture during their push off for
on one hand the interest in
standardization and vast powers and on
the other hand the interest in communal
living and design spaces for coming of
living and eventually the letter strand
was suppressed and could you sort of
speculate or how did how do you think
what was the reason and the result of
the suppression of this trend yeah it's
it doesn't need to be you know there
doesn't need to be that much speculation
as the as the building was nearing
completion there's a set of sociological
debates among sociologists a ballot that
the project and many people came to see
it not as necessarily but basically as a
house with privileges but it's called
the house in Russian the house with
collective services they called it the
house with privileges meaning that you
know although this might be a microcosm
of a future vision this is also a lot
better than average housing in the rest
of masculine rest of the Soviet Union
yeah we spoke we spoke we spoke before
but nobody wanted to live there but you
spoke of overcrowding if the units were
perhaps not necessarily in scarcity it
might have been a different problem
might have been a different project
yes yeah under the other panelist lived
in the house as well human subjects
research yes all right so on that note
we're going to wrap up and go to the
where lounge for participants there is a
lunch 64 yeah yeah